[SPEAKER_06]: He's not allowed to do it, but we don't have to do it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's some stupid jungle.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is that Neil?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, that's...
Guys, this is the last one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hi, I need to get that refund.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: $20, $40, $50.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I already took care of your other stuff in the books.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anything else I can help you with while you're here?
[SPEAKER_05]: uh no i'll probably come in here afterwards to see what's up with the other sunshine requests that i have but i haven't looked in my email for a bit your what for the other sunshine requests that i have in progress but i i'll do that afterwards thank you
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: They have that door locked, so I can go over some of these now.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so I had this one, which is the one that just got refunded for...
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so the ordinances one, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: The ordinance for the commissioner's office or the ordinance for...
[SPEAKER_05]: So, I asked for a copy of all the ordinances in the county and now I'm planning on zoning.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, like, this is a court order or an ordinance when they sign stuff.
[SPEAKER_05]: Or, like, so we don't have a book of, like...
[SPEAKER_00]: You're one of, like, all the ordinance that we have in the county total.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I would think that we would have a book of, like, here's how this place is run.
[SPEAKER_00]: You would think.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, actually, what most of the time we do is, like, for commissioners, they literally just go by what St. Satchel says what commissioners do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our offices don't really have ordinance of, like, what they do set in place.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does that make sense?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I don't know if P&Z has one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they do.
[SPEAKER_05]: I have that already.
[SPEAKER_05]: So then the other part of that one was the rules and procedures for the commissioner's meeting.
[SPEAKER_05]: So they have that sign in the back that says you have to record.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's that other ordinance from when Billy Gaines was presiding that says...
[SPEAKER_05]: what does it say like basically you have five minutes during open meetings and i didn't know if there was like other things that we have of that that's what i was looking for yeah i understand that i don't think i mean i've asked and she said that we don't but i can double check because like they make motions and yeah what is like they're using robert's rules of order like is there some document that they've adopted that governs the way that they're pursuing that no i understand completely um
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, George, you're good.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's not all we're going to do.
You're good.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know the other day they were talking about setting up an ordinance for their office.
[SPEAKER_00]: When I talked to them before, they said they didn't really have anything set in place.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's all the information that I had on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I can see if I can find those two, and then I will let you know.
[SPEAKER_05]: So then the other one was the one that you guys sent to legal.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is there any response on that one?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, waiting for legal is like waiting for...
[SPEAKER_00]: Pigs will fly.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we're waiting back from that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He is kind of midway through a trial right now, so that might be why he's taking a little bit for the trial that we have with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I don't know if that's what's taking his time right now, but we are still waiting.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will try to resend it to him, report it to him, and say, hey, is there an update on this, and see if he has anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's all I have.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okie dokie.
[SPEAKER_05]: You have a good one.
You are God.
[SPEAKER_06]: You are God.
Thank you.
... ... ...
[SPEAKER_06]: Come on.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I'm just looking for the church prayer.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't, I don't know what we're looking at.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it's, it's just a, it's just a, it's just a, it's just a,
[SPEAKER_06]: I just want what she used to be.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't care about the name.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm married.
Good morning.
How are you?
How's everybody?
Good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Good, too.
[SPEAKER_03]: We are.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going to bring it to that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe that's why he didn't return my phone the other day.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, all right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I never know because I don't look after it.
I do it once a week, though.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll see you later.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did I run right off or was he finished?
[SPEAKER_03]: I hope he's finished.
[SPEAKER_03]: He sneaked out.
[SPEAKER_06]: We have a short conversation about upcoming work on .
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, we just have to do some as we go.
[SPEAKER_06]: We've got to fix some of these things.
[SPEAKER_06]: Some just need to sit there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Some need to be on a laptop.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did the company that did that, did they ever come?
[SPEAKER_06]: We haven't heard from them.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, they were supposed to.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, they were.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then the other end, you just have to keep after it like this.
I don't know why you're here.
[SPEAKER_06]: oh okay the first one i didn't get done okay this is just a quarter yes i'll scan and make sure and then i'll get back
[SPEAKER_03]: And we won't do the pledge of a prayer.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was just a carryover from last week since we weren't here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, did you guys get on there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I did.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bye.
Okay, thank you.
Come on in.
Let's see if we can get this done.
Get this out of the way.
Okay.
That's all I have to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
I'm not dead.
We'll send that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll email them and see if they haven't revised.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think you don't have a helper today.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, she's at grandma's today.
[SPEAKER_01]: My sister's always independent, so it's kind of hard to decide if I want to keep her all day with me or drive out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus, she's free, so...
[SPEAKER_03]: a gasp at the time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a struggle.
[SPEAKER_01]: How old is she?
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: She seems pretty happy when she's with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some kids are.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the whole reason I say I don't want to have another kid.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think I would get another one that behaves as well as her and just doesn't do anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's certainly discipline.
[SPEAKER_06]: See, they tricked you to have a second one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not always.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're naive.
[SPEAKER_06]: You keep going, huh?
[SPEAKER_03]: They're so cute when they look old.
[SPEAKER_06]: What were we thinking?
[SPEAKER_02]: Was she liking that school job, or does she like school a lot?
[SPEAKER_01]: She always likes school for the last couple months, and then she's done.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: The pharmacy.
[SPEAKER_02]: The pharmacy, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: and figure out the criteria.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I have stuff in my mind that will help me with that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's almost like...
[SPEAKER_03]: One of the things that we did was you tell us what you can do for us.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, you tell us what you can provide.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I think it's time to go.
[SPEAKER_03]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_03]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, this meeting is in session.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we are videoing and audio recording.
[SPEAKER_03]: Any comments?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, it's not here yet.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right, and then there was a sunshine request that I submitted.
[SPEAKER_05]: April 4th, I believe, so it's been two months, and they've got sent to legal, and I have no response still.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I think you just asked one thing about that, is that correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: She told you it's in legal, so we're waiting for legal.
[SPEAKER_05]: through budget stuff about, there was a bunch of stuff that I asked, but I think it was related to the budget around the hack that happened last year.
[SPEAKER_05]: There was a bunch of stuff, and I'd like to say two months, so I can't recall exactly how that happened, but are you, have you thought about it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I go on, like, what's the whole thing?
[SPEAKER_06]: We can't push them along, so we already use them a lot.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we don't push them along because they've already got a lot on their plate for us.
[SPEAKER_06]: So Lindsey's following up for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then have you guys read the state auditor's report that I brought up last week?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: In there it says that the sometime request process is partially implemented, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: That was back when Glenda was in office.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that was not, I wasn't even here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think you misread the audit.
[SPEAKER_02]: A lot of this audit.
[SPEAKER_05]: The audit report was just released in the 26th.
[SPEAKER_05]: For the audit report.
[SPEAKER_05]: Or 2025.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is for 2025, but it also goes back because there were unfinished points.
[SPEAKER_03]: And those points.
[SPEAKER_03]: There was only really one session, or one session that really pertained to us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, the Sunshine Request.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we discussed that.
[SPEAKER_05]: So it says that's partially that Sunshine Request processes, and then it's partially the one that they're talking about, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not sure I understand what you're saying or what.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I was trying to make a point, and the point is...
[SPEAKER_04]: the last page of the second class.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's what they should, they should .
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so on the first page, partially implemented says the definition of that is that you're not working towards implementing the rest of the code.
[SPEAKER_03]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we are, as we told you last week, we are working on making our closed sessions to be sure that those closed sessions.
[SPEAKER_05]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm trying to understand if there's a discrepancy between what you are saying and what this report says.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we're saying the same thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're saying that we're following that.
[SPEAKER_06]: In spite of what the auditor's report may say or may not say, we worked on it.
[SPEAKER_06]: We worked on it yesterday.
[SPEAKER_06]: We are continuing to work on it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, that's, thank you, because that is what, that is all I'm trying to say.
[SPEAKER_05]: We didn't quit.
[SPEAKER_05]: In spite of, right.
[SPEAKER_05]: That may be their opinion, but we did not.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so I would clarify with them why they said that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to.
[SPEAKER_05]: I was trying to get back to what they were thinking.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's all I have.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anything else?
[SPEAKER_03]: Miranda, do you have anything?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, ma'am.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we have something from ODOT that we need to sign.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, this is from a guy named Tucker, and just as a quick information, I can't believe you tried to guarantee I would find for them to upgrade their system for all their other big brothers.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just signed it once.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's nothing regarding my parents.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just something that they have for a moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've already heard about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's great.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, she is really good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very, very helpful.
[SPEAKER_02]: 30?
[SPEAKER_06]: 30 is over.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, well, they, yeah, no.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, for the class.
[SPEAKER_06]: Two different things.
[SPEAKER_06]: Two different things, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: They're going to be to the first.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Tom's out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tom's out, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I have to schedule.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, yeah, I got you.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a long email.
[SPEAKER_03]: That rolls off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's the only other thing we have as part of the class today.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the work session's off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Time is off.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then we have a closed session.
[SPEAKER_06]: So are we waiting on MTS for a rebid on handrails?
[SPEAKER_06]: Or are we going to investigate whether it's likely?
[SPEAKER_03]: They know that, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: They know about, I know we're waiting on the invoices, the new invoices that covers some of the changes, but the railing, they are aware of making, giving us a new bed on the rail.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you guys can talk to Wayne, then yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we're waiting on it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I have no doubt in this for now.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I did email Allie just to be sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have edits in a file somewhere on a loading factor from Murphy?
[SPEAKER_06]: Or did I file those in my own file?
[SPEAKER_02]: But I'll double check.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can double check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or if you tracked it, I remember we talked about it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So if we say we want it right now, it's going to be two years before we get it approved.
[SPEAKER_06]: 24 weeks.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was going to say, that doesn't do us much good.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, and when we started the process, I don't think I was aware exactly of how all the equipment was used and what we had elsewhere.
[SPEAKER_06]: We do have two pathway modes for that.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is especially more than just the brush and eye out and the limbs and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And nobody has it ready to go.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, and when I talked to Craig recently, you know, we went without it for almost a year anyway because it's in shock.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we can make do until we get it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, yeah, I'd like to have it sooner.
[SPEAKER_06]: But the only sooner we can get it, then, is if we make the decision and move forward.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where was the other bid from?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, we had one bid from Murphy through Sourcewell, which is the way it's legally done.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now, Murphy gave us two different options of that bid, but the one was an underpowered, undersized, and probably wouldn't work when you're putting more than 30 feet in there.
[SPEAKER_06]: You need more stability on the ground.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I want to flip this over, when I looked at Oprah, this is what the agreement is currently.
[SPEAKER_03]: And to me, that's the document.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is kind of the criteria.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if anybody...
[SPEAKER_03]: This is the summary.
[SPEAKER_03]: I looked it over and to me this was doable.
[SPEAKER_03]: This seemed...
[SPEAKER_03]: But again, if we could do local, I think it would help us at lots of levels.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'd love to have someone from Red Canyon provide that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think I'll ever get that.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, while we can do that, and that's the same thing with CBS.
[SPEAKER_03]: The only Red Canyon one that I know of is at Barks, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, that's the...
[SPEAKER_03]: We have a few minutes.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're waiting on the funding.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you see how great the radio is?
[SPEAKER_06]: I did.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you?
[SPEAKER_03]: I did.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did you guys notice that?
[SPEAKER_06]: I did.
[SPEAKER_03]: It really does look good.
[SPEAKER_03]: I find myself when I walk by it like I want to.
[SPEAKER_03]: i'm just trying to take it and take it
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is she thinking about it just as a... Whatever.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, I mean, she said all she's doing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that we have to go with it.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's just my opinion.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, and that would be fine, but I think she's even more unsure if she wanted to do it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, absolutely, because that has to be kept.
So it makes sense to sit here.
Because we have to keep up on those tickets and follow them.
[SPEAKER_05]: We posted that at 11 yesterday on board.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's an emergency session for personnel.
[SPEAKER_03]: Statute 610.0213.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did we pass a resolution to sell it to him?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: His papers come back up to the top.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not sure if it's going to change some of the time.
[SPEAKER_06]: It is for everyone.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm afraid.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's ongoing, isn't it?
[SPEAKER_06]: We just finished high school soccer, and now we're starting on a club team.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, there's so many kids.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's probably maybe...
[SPEAKER_03]: So these kids have had to go out and try out for these club teams.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, you know, there were a couple that wanted one and not the other.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't when you're driving kids.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you're doing practice, some of them out at Legends, some of them at Waste Summit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, the one they chose is at Riverside, they practiced there anyway.
[SPEAKER_03]: But you can't have two kids going in different directions or over here and over there.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then you add the game time to it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Kristen just said, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going with whatever team.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're on high school, but we're going with whatever team.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's just...
[SPEAKER_06]: Girls soccer, who would have thought?
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I would never.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to send you something and you can't give it to your parents.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, there's very little about the agreement here.
[SPEAKER_03]: It has the cost of all the drugs, which... Maybe.
[SPEAKER_06]: We can probably come up with something along the lines of that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, I think we need more of this when we follow up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you want to help me?
[SPEAKER_06]: It's just, you know, I don't want to do this.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't want to do this.
Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: is for me to understand it.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, I think if we get them to something like the law, that's going to be the first thing we've got.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because it's been done, and it's been used a lot.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: But the ones that's killed, this is the ones that they don't have to bear it for.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, they can go to that.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like a different medication.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can have the other one.
[SPEAKER_06]: I like to think we'll have the other one.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We thought that we were going to be recreated and find a substitute, and it was, what, $300 more, the substitute that they recommended.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I'm not hiring you.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that was not a good thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: We thought we were on that case, and we thought we were going to figure it out.
[SPEAKER_05]: You're talking about the pharmacy part, the drugs for the inmates, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hi.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, first of all, I just wonder how that works.
[SPEAKER_03]: If somebody's booked on the 79th, they have a certain drug.
[SPEAKER_03]: I wonder how long, and it doesn't say anything when I turn around the time.
[SPEAKER_03]: Whereas if it's 2 million, I don't know that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Here's the answer.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's male.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, surely they don't have courage.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess we never know what these people think about women.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're not doing it.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not doing it now.
[SPEAKER_03]: We had a work session and we're not doing a work session now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you're not?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Some things came up with their schedule.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we won't.
[SPEAKER_03]: We won't.
[SPEAKER_03]: Perfect.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, next question.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is an apple, and this is covered back.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not one and covered.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is back.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it's interesting that some of those poster bags, can't you call it, because I wasn't sure what they were.
[SPEAKER_03]: Of course, you see these and others.
You almost have to get a knife and...
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, let me know if there's anything.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: What is this?
[SPEAKER_02]: i had no idea it's been here way before i was here so i bet they don't even like that anymore i think it's so i think it's cool if i saw that at a sale
[SPEAKER_04]: I wonder if you can see it on the table.
[SPEAKER_05]: They probably used like wax back then.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not sure what's there.
[SPEAKER_03]: It almost looks like a bottle of liquor.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's see if I can see that right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like sitting on top of those papers.
[SPEAKER_03]: I believe that the day...
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a different picture but it's the same.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was there.
[SPEAKER_03]: What are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_04]: You have one of those old phones that you hang up the thing like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I have one of those in my family room.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you know, I took my
[SPEAKER_03]: Because my kids gave me such a hard time that I had it on the wall and they would go, .
[SPEAKER_03]: And they gave me such a hard time, I took it out, redid the wall,
[SPEAKER_03]: I am so sad that I did that because I loved it there.
[SPEAKER_03]: I loved the look of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's gone.
[SPEAKER_03]: The kids may be such a hard time.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't listen to them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I remember Grandma had one of those.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the cord was like 22 pounds.
[SPEAKER_02]: How old are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: How old was I?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm 45.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I could, and one of the girls that was in my class even had a party line.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what we had.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, I would call, I didn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have that much?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm addicted to the same talk.
[SPEAKER_03]: Carrie's ex-husband used to tease me.
[SPEAKER_03]: He would say, when we come here, if we call 911, we'll jump.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then we upgraded the push button, which everybody thought was fantastic.
[SPEAKER_02]: My grandpa had a back phone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your cell phone, you know, where you... Oh, yeah, I had one.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was the first one I had.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was huge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pick up that big old thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Heavy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm packing around with you.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that was...
[SPEAKER_03]: I was in.
[SPEAKER_03]: When I looked at the chamber and then the prison, I was like...
I feel really bad for you.
Aw.
Happy birthday.
My son's a star.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he'll be.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least we're talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's Chris's?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, she's two and a half years younger than me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Kurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have all this typed up for you, and I printed it, and then I woke up in front of her, and I was like, wait a minute.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you're fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just can't do it.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there a stopping point?
[SPEAKER_03]: The kids just tell stories about how we were raising them, but I don't know how they met each other.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sure they have kids with their mother, and they start together.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm on the whole time, like, I swear to God.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was looking at that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: The paper was really, really thin, I noticed, because these others don't see the back side.
[SPEAKER_03]: It seems like it's easier to sign.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_03]: It seems like it holds better.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, when I first started, when we did class, we had to have a mylar copy, too, which was like that plastic thing.
They've been around.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think that's the one that...
[SPEAKER_02]: There was another one with...
[SPEAKER_02]: I got the other one up there, but I don't know how this one...
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have any idea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is the other one over?
[SPEAKER_02]: I just thought you'd been here for a while.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it would be 25, 12 plus.
[SPEAKER_02]: 25, 12.
[SPEAKER_03]: So are you now the senior?
[SPEAKER_03]: Close, I think.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know that you're not... Because Kent was retired and...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was Julie here when I started, maybe?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I don't think Julie was any close.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, she wasn't a collector, but she worked with Margie because she did my job.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, she did?
[SPEAKER_02]: For a while, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So maybe it's Julie.
[SPEAKER_06]: So this can be an argument.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know where they actually do the printing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, you know what?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would suspect it did or he had to take it to Kansas City somewhere and actually have it printed because...
[SPEAKER_03]: That one, it's a good word, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: because every 15 days, you know, you're starting to prep for the next meeting and it just...
[SPEAKER_06]: It's non-stop.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is, and it's like, you're getting like the year goes so fast, too, because you're always ahead of where you're at.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so these are rezoning ordinances.
[SPEAKER_03]: So then next month we will get these for these.
[SPEAKER_03]: I like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm glad that we're up to that process.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kurt, I see the school went to your house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you sell their furniture?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, it's just in my house.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I think I've had it before and I was like, oh, that's interesting.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you selling it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you provide it for any restaurants?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, not yet.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't have enough stock.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you don't do anything with their wool?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, they don't have wool.
[SPEAKER_04]: Only one has wool.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't realize that was a thing either.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I just assumed that she might have wool, but there's a lady whose dad is out at Oak Ridge, and she said the same thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: They might not have wool, and I'm like, okay.
Yeah, they're shedding.
They look terrible.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Well, I don't think so.
If they don't want to get rid of the car wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
I think we had it down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do you take it, the process?
The one I was talking about was in St. Joe.
Oh, yeah, okay.
I've never been up there.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Plaza, what is that weird restaurant's name?
[SPEAKER_02]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I was going to say.
[SPEAKER_04]: Most people, yeah, like, tend to, like, agree on this.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll pass on this one.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just don't like it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't like deer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, God, I love it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Deer jerky, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, deer jerky.
[SPEAKER_02]: We get sausage all the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would love you to do sticks or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: we don't
[SPEAKER_06]: with that shot right where it needs to go.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is interesting.
[SPEAKER_05]: I've never even heard of that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You said you live in Italy?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I was a foreign exchange student there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: I would love to live in Italy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where in Italy?
[SPEAKER_04]: Near Milan, there's a small criminal there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, God.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I've been three times.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: okay girl i will shoot you that email yes at least thank you at least i got them typed up yeah
[SPEAKER_05]: You're talking about travel through the neighborhood.
[SPEAKER_04]: Friends that we don't like.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not as much friends.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, they're not as exceptional?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: They speak less English than we do, but since the last time I've been there, it's a lot more English.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's one of my friends in Ireland.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a best friend that lives in Wales.
[SPEAKER_02]: I always want to go out and see it.
She's so great.
Out there in the military, he said it's beautiful.
And he tried whale.
He said whale is really good.
It's actually super good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm trying to think.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would think it would be like squishy or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fishy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fishy, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: That was cool, too, because one of my friends, her family used to be, like, all the rest of us.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I went to her 18th birthday palace, and I'm, like, walking around the house, just, like, admiring the house while they're, like, everyone's partying together.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was so cool, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: We stayed in a...
[SPEAKER_03]: Of course, they had turned this place into, it was the, what's the beer in Ireland?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, it was that family years ago that done this, and then they turned it into, you know, a place that was on tours, but it was.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just to even fly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Probably the best deal, of course, I did these trips through the chamber.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was just something that our chamber did.
[SPEAKER_03]: They made a lot of money doing it, and I got to go, so I didn't have to pay for it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And, you know, we would make maybe $5,000 for a trip like that, you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anywhere.
[SPEAKER_03]: One time we had 40 people that went to China.
[SPEAKER_03]: But going to China for a week, this is crazy.
[SPEAKER_03]: For one week.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we were staying in nice hotels.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, really nice hotels.
[SPEAKER_03]: With light, food, almost all the food.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, there was breakfast and lunch most of the time, or breakfast and dinner.
[SPEAKER_03]: eighteen hundred dollars for the flight that was what 13 years ago i mean it was unbelievable it's not like it like where i wouldn't want to do it it was a trip that was incredible but it's not someplace
[SPEAKER_03]: But I didn't want to go again.
[SPEAKER_03]: But it was.
[SPEAKER_03]: And going to all the places.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, we went to the Great Wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: We went to the top of that.
[SPEAKER_03]: We went to 10th and Square.
[SPEAKER_03]: We went to all kinds of palaces.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it was an incredible trip.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was a long time.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it was 14 hours from California to, I think it went from California to Shanghai, and then from Shanghai to Beijing.
[SPEAKER_03]: It goes to South Africa, and does the big ones out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't you know that?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a no-go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he loves it out there in Beijing.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have books that kind of go straight when I'm confused, but I think we were at a place in Spain looking across all over the sea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Does that make sense?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen the ocean just one time.
[SPEAKER_01]: I went to Texas once and that was it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So technically the goal of that thing doesn't count.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it always counts.
[SPEAKER_03]: It always counts.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I think that's all we have until we have our first session.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anything?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do we want to just do this?
[SPEAKER_03]: Under other business, and then if we need to make a motion, we will put it on next week.
Right?
Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Talk this down.
[SPEAKER_03]: For a future.
[SPEAKER_06]: For a future.
[SPEAKER_06]: Would it have been on an email that you
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I don't have it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is he done?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he's retired.
That was a good weekend.
You too.
Thank you.
Have a good one.
[SPEAKER_02]: three let me one of you to sign those those four payables i just got it
[SPEAKER_03]: 24 weeks.
[SPEAKER_06]: That summit that had been 24 months?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, it is.
[SPEAKER_06]: What's the concern?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, this is the one we were talking about.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've been talking to the government department.
[SPEAKER_06]: This one has a 50-day challenge.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I can read it.
[SPEAKER_06]: What you're getting, it's not a lot of difference.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, can we put that on the agenda for next week to approve that or to consider that, the bids for a new mower, tractor mower?
[SPEAKER_02]: Heather, do you want a master set?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want the running order?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll need it one thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll do it that way.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you have a copy for your father?
Mm-hmm.
I'll just do that.
Okay, I think that's all we can do until 11.
Let's see.
11.